[Music]
if you're watching this thing you know
by now a huge problem is heading our way
an emergency meeting is being called our
youtube plays immediately shrink bagels
i've made a shocking discovery
need you to get me in touch with nasa
immediately well nasa and i aren't
really on speaking terms these days well
that'll change
when you tell them that the moon is out
of orbit
there's no need to panic not spacey
why are they lying about all this
it's too late to stop
you knew all this was happening before
nasa
you're the unidentified source oh yes
we're dealing with an intelligent entity
we're planning a mission to attack this
thing
i'm asking you for your help
say yes brian
i need you to be brave
if the moon really is what you think it
is
suit up
horizon you have got a big gravity wave
coming your way you have to launch now
did he say gravity wave
we're underwater guys
uh that's crazy
what's the plan save the mill and save
earth
wait for it
let's go you son
[Music]
everybody hang on i'm gonna get you
[Music]
home it's on airplane mode
[Music]
ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week
where my life has felt normal
that was when you found out
[Music]
when you botched that spell where you
wanted everyone to forget the peter
parker spiderman
we started getting some visitors
[Applause]
from every
universe
hello peter
you're not peter parker
i'm sorry what was your name again dr
otto octavius
[Laughter]
wait no seriously what's your actual
name
there are others out there we need to
send them back
so
scooby doo this crap you know all this
is kind of your mess i know a couple of
magic words myself starting with the
word please
please
scooby-doo this crap
you're flying out into the darkness
to fight ghosts what do you mean
they all die fighting spider-man
it's their fate
i'm sorry kid
yeah me too don't
look there has to be another way there
isn't
they're a danger to our universe
you know to take this away from me
peter
you're struggling
to have everything you want
while the world tries to make you choose
this is all my fault i can't save
everyone
[Applause]
what's happening they're starting to
come through
and i can't stop them
[Music]
tell me something
[Music]
you can go
anywhere you want right
any timeline
and the universe
[Music]
why do you want to stay
and fight to save this one
you change the future
and you change the past
are you in
oh
[Music]
mrs wang are you with us
i am paying attention
now you may only see a pile of receipts
but i see a story
i can see where this story is going
it does not look
good
[Music]
one of the versions of him from another
universe i'm here because we need your
help
very busy today so time to help you
across the multiverse
i've seen thousands of
you evelyn's access all the memories
their emotions
even their skills
there's a great evil spreading the many
verses
and you
may be your only chance of stopping it
don't make me find you i am really good
i don't believe you
the universe he speaks
all the places i could be
i just want you to share with you
remember our mission concerning the fate
of every single world of our infinite
motives
there is no way i am the everlane you
are looking for
every rejection
every disappointment
has led you here
to this
let anything moment you from it
[Music]
[Music]
flight recorders are on t-minus five
four
three
two
one
zero
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
to infinity and
who's swaying
sorry i wouldn't be bothering you here
but your people keep telling me you're
unavailable
you know you really could be doing more
for this city
my family has a history of philanthropy
but as far as i can tell you're not
doing
[Music]
anything the riddler
is asking for you the killer left this
for the batman why is he lying to you
you came
i've been trying to reach you
look at this latest it's all about the
wings
if we don't stand up no one will
you got a lot of cats everything about
strikes
the bat and the cat
it's got a nice ring new friend of yours
i'm not so sure
i'm just here to unmask the truth about
this cesspool we call a city
you're part of this too
oh you're really not as smart as i
thought you were
bruised
away
all these years your life to be over
we all have our scars bruce he's still a
wine
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know she suffered
delaney
why are you under there
don't worry honey i get nine of them
it can be cruel poetic or blind
but when it's denied
it's your violence you may find
justice
the answer's justice
come on
let's
vengeance
into some trouble
[Music]
we can't see it
but we're all trapped inside these
strange repeating loops
billions of people just living out their
lives
oblivious
but this is the moment for you to show
us what is real
[Music]
i remember this
[Music]
so deja vu
and yet it's obviously all wrong
maybe this isn't the story we think it
is
they taught you good
made you believe their world was all you
deserved
but some part of you knew that was a lie
some part of you remembered what was
real
it's so easy to forget how much noise
the matrix pumps into your head
something else makes the same kind of
noise
war
what happens to
neander the most important choice in
neil's life
it's not his demand
she believed in me
it's my turn to believe in her
[Music]
part of me feels like i have been
waiting my whole life for you
if you want to see trinity again
i saw this in a dream
my dream ended here
[Music]
i still know kung fu
don't guess that spell it's too
dangerous why we tampered with the
stability of space time
the multiverse
is a concept about which we know
frighteningly little
your desecration
it was the only way
but i never
meant for any of this to happen
[Music]
later you'd show up
i made mistakes
and people were hurt i'm not here to
talk about westview
then what are you here for
i need your help
guess what
what do you know about the multiverse
[Music]
i'm sorry steven
i hope you understand
the greatest threat
to our universe
is you
things just got out of hand
[Music]
what are you doing here in somerville
anyway honestly my mom won't say it but
we're completely broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name
is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
[Music]
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate that has no fault lines
no fracking no loud music even
is shaking on a daily basis
under the dining table now
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room
killer replica a replica of what
a ghost trap
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
[Music]
my grandfather died
my mom says we're just here to pick
through the roblox life
wait a minute
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it faith
call it lock
call it karma
[Music]
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
[Music]
oh
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
if you're being reckless don't worry
nobody's gonna get hurt
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
hope i'm not too late
i'm sorry who are you memes tales okay
this is what we're gonna do step one
light taunting step two i have no idea
[Music]
that wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for a 100 chance
of adventure
[Music]
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
[Applause]
how long do we have
seven days
we're eternals
[Music]
we came here 7000 years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
[Music]
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts unless deviants are
involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
[Applause]
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
[Music]
any of them
[Music]
i bet you've built the perfect safe
house what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
[Music]
my case i've
she's down
so
[Applause]
what do i know that you need so bad
that's why you're here
to find out
[Applause]
you're not crazy
you never have been
do you find yourself drawn to places
you've never been
the visions you've had your entire life
aren't hallucinations
their memories they're talking about
reincarnation the legend never die
we call ourselves the infinite we
remember skills from all our past lives
[Music]
it takes 10 000 hours to master a skull
how could you just be after a million
hours
pretty damn good
what do i know that you need so bad
that's why you're here to find out we
have fought one another
for centuries
but you can't stop what's coming
the end of all things
is he blocked well well well we're gonna
have to reset your memory
you're gonna drown me i gotta think
about drowning which is i don't like it
you know what man i like you this time
around shut up and turn it on
[Music]
there's still time time
no more time
the legend never dies
[Music]
[Music]
don't you think your mom would want you
to be happy
come be in the picture with that
happy
but how
[Music]
welcome to the world of you
you may not be able to start over in the
real world
but you can start over
in the world of you
with its unique body sharing technology
you would be able to draw out a user's
hidden strength
i can finally sing again
she made it unused global music charts
just as i expected i'm so sad
nobody in their right mind would ever
ask that bell's user is actually a mousy
nobody like you i guess it's true that
everyone's hiding some kind of secret
susie something wrong
why are you still here wait who is that
a dragon this is typical internet
behavior why does he do stuff that'll
make people hate him
preserve the peace in you this creature
must be disposed of
who are you really
he's in danger
[Music]
how are we supposed to find one out of
five billion accounts
actually there's something i've been
meaning to ask you for quite a long time
now
when the truth is revealed what do you
want to bet no one will pay any
attention to a single one of your songs
[Music]
sing
do you need a doctor
i am a doctor
i should have died years ago
people all over the world have my
disease from here
to find a cure
we have to push the boundaries take the
risks
if you're gonna run
do it now
dr michael morbius you've been missing
for two months when you're a stranger
then you were found on a container ship
that washed up off a long island
when you're alone
what did you do to yourself doctor
i wish i knew
i went from dying to being more alive
than ever it worked
not exactly i have increased strength
and speed
and some form of bad radar
what else can i do
[Music]
there are limits there has to be there's
something inside of him
he wants to hunt
and consume blood
and you control it
we haven't had anything this good since
that thing in san francisco
the other half wants to control you hey
dr mike you and i should stay in touch
i'd do anything to save a life
but i don't know what i'm capable of
you save lives you don't take
them you here to heal the world
or to destroy it
who the hell are you mad i
am i know
i'm just kidding it's dr michael
morvious at your service
that was a terrible crash
we'll look it to be alive
[Music]
stop don't come any closer
it's a girl
oh my gosh girl
i'm sorry no move blonde hair i've just
never ever seen a girl before
who are you
it's so loud here
we call it the noise
happened to all the men on this planet
every thought in our heads
on display
where are all the women
the dead
[Music]
why is she thinking where the hell is
your noise it's strange to see
everything you're thinking it was
strange for me too not knowing what's
going on in your head i mean i know you
might not like my dog or you want to hit
me over the head with a rock or
something
i like your dog
[Music]
they'll kill you
[Music]
if you want to protect the girl you have
to leave now
keep you safe keep you safe safe
with her power there's no telling what
he can do
i need that girl before she wants him
come in here coming
100
200
thousands
[Music]
[Music]
it's gonna be a beautiful wedding
here you are standing on the precipice
of something so much bigger than anyone
here but always remember you are not
alone i don't think that we met i'm
sarah niles hi hi
[Music]
don't come in here
it's gonna be a beautiful wedding
good day so far today tomorrow it's all
the same you what is going on hey get
out of the water
i guess you followed me it's one of
those infinite time loop situations you
might have heard about that i might have
heard about yeah
the second you fall asleep it all just
goes back to the start i drove all the
way back home to austin and i still woke
up here one time i smoked a bunch of
crystal and made it all the way to
equatorial guinea it was a huge waste of
time
well then what's the point of flipping
we kind of have no choice but to live no
i'm gonna get out of this
suit yourself
see you tomorrow
so now what do we do you just have to
embrace the fact that nothing matters do
you sleep with people in here great
question i have but it takes a lot of
work yeah i got in
it's the first dance and that's a deal
breaker
that didn't work
let's waste some time
[Music]
you're right
got him
[Music]
i hope it's not all meaningless
at least you have each other nothing
worse than going through this [ __ ] alone
stop
there's a bomb in the cake don't worry i
used to be a bomb guy stand back
[Music]
i still can't believe it are you gonna
fall in love with a new little person
again
just breathe
i'm gonna count down from three
and on three
and two
[Music]
i can't lie to my family anymore
[Music]
the second you tell your wife that you
are dying
your opportunity to do this is gone
[Music]
you want to go say hi
[Music]
[Music]
so he has everything even the memories
you store deep in your subconscious
do this with us and let life go on for
your family a clean swap
if
i thought i had more time i guess
you have an opportunity here i'm not
done i didn't say he could not die
i feel like i fallen in love with her
for the first time again
no i'm like this you think i like this
being told i'm not me because you're not
me
you are not me
i love you cam antenna
[Music]
well they say kids never come by unless
they need something
dad i need your help
i'll get my coat
30 years in the future we are fighting a
war our enemy is not human
and we are losing we need you to fight
i will be back
and i love you chickpea
seven days from now when you're sent
into that war
won't be fighting for your country
you'll be fighting for the world is it
all right yeah going to war stop talking
listen sorry i mean that's when i'm
nervous at talk i'm like 1997 on the
nervous
scale that should be fun
welcome to the future
you and your unit are now in 2051.
they're everywhere we are food and they
are hungry
our enemy is smarter
faster
and stronger than you can possibly
imagine
do you want to see something really
dangerous if you like literally that's
all i've been doing since i got here but
okay
within the next few weeks the human
species won't disappear from the face of
the earth nothing we do here matters
that's where you're wrong
i don't believe that one bit
together we can stop this war
from ever happening
this is my opportunity to give this
world a second chance
second chances are really hard to come
by
fireball
i'm not gonna hide
i'm gonna fight it's not even loaded
yeah well yeah it's not loaded it's a
pressurized cabin why would i load it in
the cabin the bullet goes in thing and
everybody sucked out
she was called mother earth
we plundered everything she offered
none of us should have come back
where i'm from all reproductive
technology efforts failed for both men
and women i want to prove that we can
procreate here
on earth
you came to earth on the first mission
we waited so long
it's imperative that we give future
generations the chance of civilization
and bring our people home
for the money
for the
[Music]
money who are they
survivors
months we called them
i saw a child
we can repopulate our planet
there are children they won't be by the
time our people arrive
keep an eye on her
my daughter
where is she
i want to help you
let's go
are you still with us blake
our predecessors failed us in so many
ways
are they coming
let's get out of here
trust me
for them
it takes more than guns to kill a man
you think i'm your enemy
i am your enemy
but your enemy won't be gone when you
kill me
your brother is still in prison
your twin brother was an anarchist
my brother was a revolutionary
somebody was up to something i wanted to
be a part of it
ask help from no one
where is he
cameraman is my brother
he won't last 10 minutes on the street
knowing what he knows
this
is a battleground
who's the contact
russia goodbye tell me so when is this
gonna happen it has happening for a
thousand years
we had a deal
your brother can expose everything
i have done what is mine to do
the world is watching what happens here
it's on
is he here now i would light myself on
fire
how come no one is lighting themselves
on fire
where's my brother
i'm gonna die
[Music]
thomas ernest mother
ex-cop
convicted of murder in a burglary gone
wrong
apex is quite simple
they're hunters
you are the prey
what's the price if i kill all the
hunters
win and i can guarantee your freedom
[Music]
my good hunters
welcome sign me a real challenge
who the hell is that
do we get a refund if we kill this guy
within an hour
you're good kid i'm better than good i'm
bacon and eggs on sunday morning
malone has defied death more times than
most navy seals
simply put the universe just can't seem
to kill him
[Music]
man like that never should have come to
a place like this
let's remind malone who is the hunter
and who is the
i
prey
it's all i do
that won't be happening
bring me the head of thomas malone
you're only logical choices to beg beg
me to let you live
this ain't that kind of fight even
better
my planet arrakis is so beautiful when
the sun is low
rolling over the sands you can see spice
in the air
the outsiders ravage our lands in front
of our eyes
their cruelty to my people is all i've
known
what's to become of our world
[Music]
a boy
duncan can i trust you or something yes
always you know that
i've been having dreams
about a girl on a raccoon
i don't know what it means
dreams make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake
hey you put on some muscle i didn't no
[Applause]
we are house atreides there is no call
we do not answer
there is no faith that we betrayed
smile gurney i am smiling the emperor
asks us to bring peace to arrakis house
atreides accepts
[Music]
you need to face your fears
come with me
you need to be ready
you've never met arguments before
they're not human they're brutal
the duke's son sees too much
this is why you kill them all
[Music]
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight my demons
dad
what if i'm not the future of house of
treaties
a great man doesn't seek to lead
he's called to it
but if your answer is no
you'll still be the only thing i ever
needed you to be
my son
[Applause]
if anything happens
will you protect paul with my life
only together can we stand a chance
it's time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good evening
[Music]
oh wait
you're just a civilian now
mr james ford
[Music]
general ryan is requesting your
inimitable counsel
no
he's offered to reinstate you
[Music]
from the top
four hours ago the crew the vander made
first contact
stay there
they believe we're hostile
in the event of first contact
humanity must strike first
to ensure the continued survival
of our species
operation cosmic sin
is now a go
but there was a space gate
they can bring their army here
what's the status of the cuba
if we want to launch the cue bomb we
need to get into orbit
suit's up
that's something huh we didn't know
whether to burn it we put in a museum
i'm sure they said the same thing about
me
if we leave that door open we're going
to charge in
we can make
what we do here
is easy
the hard part
is living with it
my name is guy sunday should be warm and
sunny just a scattering of drive-bys and
i live
in paradise
i've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
mondays am i right joe you said it guys
and i work at the bank
i thought i had everything i needed
but then i met her
everybody down on the ground
everybody accept you
please i have a cold fist there's
something inside you guys i don't want
something inside me i expected you to
just follow the rules that you are so
much more than that put these on okay
fine
oh my god
what are these trick glasses or
something
guy there is no easy way to say this
this world it's a video game you're not
real
please
and the guy responsible for this world
was going to destroy it
you've met god yes he's an absolute
troll trolls exist
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters i am
sitting here with my best friend trying
to help him get through a tough time now
if that's not real i don't know what it
is
i know this world is just a game for
this place these people that's all i
have so i'm not gonna be the good guy
thanks guys i'm gonna be the great guy
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity off you go
this whole good guy routine is ruining
the game
terminator it's the
[Music]
but we have to fight together
[Music]
no
[Applause]
i can't die
[Music]
no kids allowed on the beach
oh no
we never leave each other nothing
separates us
are we there yet you said five minutes
technically it's been more than five
minutes let's just all start slowing
down
[Music]
wow you believe i found this online i
guess it's not that secret a beast
who would leave this from the hotel
they're so rusted what's happening found
stuff from the hotel in the sand
[Music]
what happened to her mom i don't know
what happened to her body has decomposed
how quickly can that happen seven years
but she just died wait where are the
kids
kara come here hey have you seen my
children mom
i'm i'm right here
dad why are you looking at me like that
[Applause]
what's happening to us
my daughter just turned six two weeks
ago
whatever's happening to us is happening
very fast you have wrinkles
there's something wrong with this beach
what's happening
people are blacking out going this way
if she makes it to the lead she might
have a chance oh she's stopping what's
she stopping can i wake up wake up
[Music]
they have to know what this place does i
don't know you're a liar look what is
that a message
we never leave each other nothing
separates us we're connected to
something bigger
oh no
we're here for a reason
[Music]
[Music]
you